THE STATE OF T-MOBILE:
Virtually
everybody in the entire world recognizes that
ringtone. For many of us, that ringtone is
not just reminiscent of a certain company
but an entire time period, the early 2000s.
A time before smartphones and smartwatches
and smart everything. Computers and cell phones
were just starting to gain popularity amongst
the general public, and ringtones were a fashion
statement, not something that you would apologize
for. But, as smartphones became more mainstream,
the popularity of ringtones fell off a cliff
and with it went the popularity of T Mobile.
This trend was only made worse by the 2008
financial recession which caused the stock
to sell off 86%. Things got so bad that T
Mobile even agreed to being bought out by
AT&T for $39 billion in 2011. But, that deal
was stopped by the US government. With nowhere
left to go, T Mobile just continued its death
dive, and during the worst of it, T Mobile
was writing off everything they had leading
to losses of over $7.5 billion. At this point,
you would think that it was just a matter
of time until T Mobile filed for bankruptcy,
but then came a new CEO, John Legere. Hopes
weren’t that high given that John didn’t
have much to work with, but somehow, over
the next 8 years, John would stage one of
the biggest comebacks of corporate history.
Since then, T Mobile has grown a mind boggling
1900% or 20X. And they have transitioned from
being the ones who needed a bailout to being
ones handing out bailouts. Likely the best
example of this is their merger, or basically
acquisition, of Sprint which propelled them
to not only be telecom juggernaut, but be
the largest telecom company in the world period.
They currently stand at a valuation of $186
billion, and fun fact, the recession hasn’t
affected their stock price whatsoever. They’re
literally floating around all times highs
as we speak. So, here’s how T Mobile went
from being so popular that they were a symbol
of a time period to near bankruptcy to becoming
the largest telecom company in the world.
NOT SO HUMBLE ORIGINS:
Taking a look back, the story of T Mobile
doesn’t actually start in America, it actually
starts in Germany, and to this day the original
T Mobile or Deutsche Telecom is still a German
giant. In fact, they’re the 6th largest
telecom company in the world and they trace
their roots all the way back to 1866 to Germany’s
national postal service Reichspost. While
the organization was technically a mail service,
they were really more of a communications
business. So, after the invention of telephones,
Reichspost was one of the first to adopt the
technology and spread it across the country.
But the real rise of Reichspost didn’t come
till the rise of Mr. Small Moustache in the
1930s and 40s. Mr. Small Moustache was well
aware of just how critical robust communication
was in trying to challenge the world powers.
So he spent a lot of resources to build up
Reichspost, and before Germany started losing,
Reichspost was stronger than ever. For obvious
reasons, the allied forces weren’t fans
of this, and after they took over, they would
shut down Reichspost in 1947. They would split
up the organization into a few smaller organizations,
the most notable of which were Deutsche Bundespost
in West Germany and Deutsche Post in East
Germany. These two organizations would essentially
remain as state owned monopolies up until
the fall of the Berlin Wall. Just a couple
of months before the collapse, West Germany
would split Duetsche Bundespost into three
sectors which included a postal service, a
postal bank, and of course, a communications
service. After the fall of the Berlin Wall,
these sectors would basically absorb the remains
of the East German services. And given that
capitalism was now the prevailing idea across
the country, Germany would eventually decide
to spinoff these sectors into public companies
at the beginning of 1995, leading to the creation
of Deutsche Telekom. Around the same time,
an American wireless communications company
called Western Wireless was starting to gain
a lot of traction. Western Wireless was founded
in 1988 and they were an early mover when
it came to wireless technology. I mean, “wireless”
is literally in their name. Given that Western
Wireless didn’t have the infrastructure
to compete against AT&T in the traditional
telephone market, they spent all of their
effort on the wireless market and more specifically
the rural wireless market which was regularly
overlooked by larger providers. It turns out
that this was actually super lucrative, and
Western Wireless would eventually grow to
compete in even non rural areas. In the meantime,
given that Deutsche Telekom was now a corporate
entity focused on profits, they would shift
their focus on aggressive expansion. They
expanded to basically every European country
you can think of from Austria and Croatia
to Slovakia and the UK, but for the purposes
of this video, we’ll focus on their expansion
to the US. This came in 2000 with the purchase
of a subsidiary of Western Wireless called
Voicestream Wireless for a ridiculous $50.7
billion. Fortunately, they would negotiate
this down to $30 billion, but Voicestream
wasn’t worth anywhere near $30 billion either.
Deutsche Telekom bought the absolute top of
the dotcom bubble, and when the crash came
around, their stock would fall 90% and never
recover. But, on the brightside, they now
owned what we all know as T Mobile.
GETTING DESTROYED BY AT&T:
While Deutsche Telekom likely overpaid for
Voicestream by a full 10X, it wasn’t all
bad news. At the end of the day, Voicestream
was still growing rapidly and Deutsche Telekom
had a bunch of money that they could throw
at Voicestream to try to win the US market.
In the early 2000s this worked out great,
and this is why we all remember the T mobile
jingle to this day. But, T mobile had one
major weakness which is that they weren’t
actually doing anything particularly noteworthy
or innovative. They were basically just riding
the wave of wireless adoption. And while this
worked out decently while the market was still
exponentially growing, the same could not
be said about the mature market. You see,
once the cool factor of having a cell phone
wore off, people actually started to value
the quality of the connection. And let’s
just say, the quality of T Mobile was absolute
garbage. While this made customers quite mad
and irritated, it wasn’t enough to kill
T Mobile altogether. Something that was enough
to kill T Mobile though was AT&T. AT&T had
been watching this whole saga from the sidelines.
For the entirety of the 1900s, they were the
undisputed king of telecom. Even government
mandated breakups couldn’t destroy their
power. But, now, all of a sudden, some rural
wireless network owned by some Deutsche company
overseas was threatening AT&T’s dominance
in their home country. This was unacceptable,
and AT&T was determined to put T Mobile back
in their place. But, to do this, AT&T had
to make big bets, simply offering better service
wasn’t good enough. So, they looked back
at their history at looked at how they got
so big in the first place, and the answer
was that they were an unbreakable monopoly.
They had to recreate this monopoly and the
perfect opportunity to do this came with the
iPhone. Apple wasn’t exactly an easy company
to work with, but AT&T was willing to do whatever
it took. This included giving Apple full control
of the software, paying out Apple for every
iPhone that was sold, and probably dozens
of other clauses. But, in return Apple granted
AT&T with exclusive rights to the iPhone meaning
that if you wanted to buy an iPhone in the
US, you had to buy it with an AT&T connection.
This didn’t seem like a big deal given that
no one really knew how big the iPhone would
get, but looking back, this was likely AT&T’s
best choice of the century as they were able
to rebuild their monopoly for nearly 4 years.
It wasn’t till 2011 that Verizon would get
their hands on the iPhone. And Sprint would
also partner with Apple later that year. Back
in Germany, Deutsche Telekom had struck a
similar exclusivity deal with Apple like AT&T,
but as for T Mobile US, well they were screwed.
They would essentially seek out a bailout
from AT&T, but as we touched on at the beginning,
the government would block that from happening.
It seemed like T Mobile was gonna to share
the same fate as most of its dotcom peers.
In a last ditch effort, the company would
hire a new CEO named John Legere, and man,
this guy would do the impossible.
THE RESURRECTION OF T-MOBILE:
John wasn’t you’re typical CEO. In fact,
he was the exact opposite and he wasn’t
afraid to admit that either. And the first
thing he noticed after he took over was the
overly diplomatic nature of the telecom industry.
Everything was uptight, pristine, and closely
monitored. This was the way that AT&T and
Verizon liked it, and so everyone followed
suit. But, this strategy clearly wasn’t
working for T Mobile. Not to mention, T Mobile
had none of the pristine advantages that AT&T
or Verizon had. They didn’t have a deal
with Apple. They didn’t have a massive marketing
budget. And they didn’t have a strong network.
In fact, they had a notably crappy network.
But despite this, T Mobile was trying to act
like an equal peer to AT&T and Verizon. So,
John decided to take the opposite approach.
Instead of trying to hide who they were, John
embraced it. He realized that people were
fed up with AT&T’s predatory cell phone
contracts with loads of fine print and dozens
of hidden fees. So, he made T Mobile into
the “Un Carrier”. And the first step in
doing this was calling up Apple. John didn’t
ask Apple to give them a juicy deal. In fact,
he asked for the opposite. He asked if they
could sell the iPhone for MSRP. Given that
this didn’t seem threatening to AT&T or
Verizon, Apple had an easy time agreeing.
And with that, T Mobile finally got the iPhone
in 2013 and they embraced who they were. Yeah,
they were crappy, they were the cheap, and
yes having a T Mobile connection would probably
hurt your social status. But, guess what,
they’re not gonna overcharge you or screw
you over with the fine print. There was also
absolutely no contracts or cancellation fees.
And for tens of millions of Americans who
had been screwed over by AT&T and Verizon
for decades, this is exactly what they wanted.
But, this didn’t mean that people switched
over instantly. In fact, it was a rather slow
burn because people didn’t quite trust T
Mobile. I mean, there’s no way that a carrier
was actually acting decent and reasonable
right? That breaks the laws of physics. So,
where’s the catch. Well, there actually
was no catch, but the general public only
started to believe this once their daring
friends and family confirmed that there was
no catch. This strategy destroyed T Mobiles
margins as they lost out on all of the predatory
revenue. AT&T, for example, generally has
net margins of 10%. Meanwhile, T Mobile was
barely able to crack net margins of 2-4%.
But, something that T Mobile had that no one
else did was happy customers and this translated
to exponential growth. In the last 10 years,
T Mobile’s annual revenue has rocketed from
$5 billion per year to $80 billion per year.
And today, T Mobile has a total of a 110 million
wireless subscribers which is about a ⅓
of the US population making them the world’s
largest telecom company.
THE COMEBACK OF T-MOBILE:
While T Mobile has maintained their generous
customer policies, they haven’t been as
stubborn when it comes to maintaining their
crappy quality. Instead, they’ve invested
much of their extra revenue back into growing
their infrastructure and making the service
better. And today, they’re actually the
leader when it comes to 5G service. According
to some research done by Opensignal, the average
5G download speed for T-Mobile was 150 Mbps.
This was three times higher than AT&T and
Verizon who scored about 50 Mbps. And speaking
from personal experience, 150 Mbps is actually
the lowside when it comes to T Mobile’s
5G speeds. If you live in popular suburbs
or urban areas, you can expect much faster
speeds. For example, I live in Austin, TX
and I regularly get download speeds above
600 Mbps. I mean, that’s literally fiber
speeds right there. So, clearly, T Mobile
is no longer just killing it in the affordability
sector, they’re also killing it in the performacne
sector as well. And that’s how T Mobie went
from being a legacy German company who tried
to win using their power and influence to
being the underdog favorite to being the global
champion. It looks like doing the right thing
does end up paying off from time to time.
Do you like your carrier? Comment that down
below. Also drop a like if all carriers were
as decent as T Mobile. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider sbuscribing
to see more questions logically answered.